100
um so back to this album man
I've heard a lot of iterations of the
album there was some music that didn't
make the album that we'll talk about why
it didn't make the album but
um because there's some there's some
stories that we'll get to there a lot of
stories of this album I feel like this
album was like a
like like a whole nother like comic book
you know what I'm saying it's like I had
to like go through
so many things to make it you know I had
to go through you know
um
uh you know shifting into you know going
over to a new label
um
uh you know um just losing friends uh
you know physical altercations all kind
of things you know all kind of drama you
know really like uh built up into this
so uh
that's why it's kind of like it's kind
of like my baby I feel like I've been
carrying this [ __ ] for like nine
months and that's finally about the drop
so it's crazy it's been a lot put into
this record man
um
I hate when people be like oh yeah this
is the most personal record
all my records personal you know what
I'm saying like I'm a person that rap
about himself so every record gonna be
you know kind of personal you know it's
just all about how you decode it and dig
into it but uh you know um
after the you know the Grammy thing
um and all of that in the course of that
man you know it was a lot of hurt a lot
of pain you know these past like 16
months you know but I'm glad that I was
able to you know culminate that into the
record though for sure